foreign
what's your name Chantelle hey Chantel
hi uh so one of the favorite things of
mine that you've ever said and I'm going
to butcher it but was that if it takes
longer for you to recover from the time
that you spend with someone than it is
the time that you spend with them
they're not the right people in your
lives something like that
um and I've recently gone no contact
with my mother for that reason and I
just going into this idea about
attachment and expectations
it just that's something that I have
really struggled with the expectations
that I had for my relationship with her
and almost the morning of that not being
what I really hoped for so I just
wondered if you had any thoughts about
it
oh I love talking about my issues with
my mother
Ryan you hate your dad don't you
you could fill a barn with the people I
hate
we have
oh I can't I kid he loves you I think
but he doesn't need you for happiness
and I yeah
and I love my mom and I love my dad
um
so
with my mother
uh she was a bad mom it's just as simple
as that and I held a lot of resentment
towards her
um same thing with my stepdad he was
even a worse you know stepdad than my
mom was a mom and I separated myself
from uh having contact with them for the
most part I'd see him every once in a
while
and I think it was like probably four or
five years ago
that I just had this
I don't know I was having this internal
dialogue where I'm like I was kind of
complaining about the situation I had
growing up and then there was like this
you know this voice that was like why do
you think you deserved anything
different
why do you think you were entitled to
anything different and I'm like oh like
that's an interesting thought because it
isn't it's an expectation it's an
entitlement that I had that wasn't being
met so now I I you know used to very
much dislike my mother and my stepdad
and then the next thing I thought was
how
um
you know I was 36 years old when I had
this thought and my mom had me at 22.
and I'm sitting there and I'm thinking
to myself
you know your mom was 22 when she had
you like she didn't really know what she
was doing like your 36 year old 36 years
old you know what you're doing and I'm
like I don't know what the hell I'm
doing like I know I know some of the
stuff I'm doing but like there's a lot I
don't know what I'm doing so for me to
have that expectation of my mother to
have it figured out at 22 and how to
raise me correctly until you know I
moved out of the house like that was I
felt it to be unfair
and ultimately I just kind of came to
the conclusion that like there's nothing
written in the fabric of the universe
that says we deserve good parents we
want it but like there's nothing that
says that that's what we're entitled to
and when I started to look at my mom's
relationship
uh that I had with her through that lens
I was able to have a bit more compassion
for her
and
you know one of the things that I used
to get upset about is how she always
wanted to tell me how
you know me and my brothers and sisters
were the cause of her problems
which made me in turn
just push her further away and be like
well you don't understand how much you
were a problem to me and we just kept
kind of going you know head to head on
that and we wouldn't listen to each
other and I I started to start to listen
to her and
I realized that I had to
kind of parent her in a way
and I started to treat her how I wish
she would have treated me and when I did
that like when I started to see
her battles and like really listen to
what she was
having issues with and
um yeah I just I I
just I can't even believe how awesome
our relationship is now because as soon
as I started to listen to her she
started to listen to me
and now like it's we have an amazing
relationship I love my mother very much
and
and uh same thing with my stepdad like I
started to look at it through that lens
as well where
um yeah I mean I just I look at her
little boy who's living in this like 70
year old
who's like just mean and angry all the
time and then I think about all the
trauma he was probably put through as a
kid and when I start to
let go of that entitlement
it helps me to see them for who they are
and that leads to more compassion so
the more you can open up for compassion
for your parents and I'm not saying
that's possible with every single
situation but that is
the best way to to start healing any
type of relationships like that in my
experience I think there's a bookend to
that as well and I love what Ryan said
about there's nothing written into the
fabric of the the universe that says I'm
entitled to good parents
but also they aren't entitled to your
time your attention your resources your
kindness your caring in fact if they've
forsaken
you for so long
you don't have to keep giving those
resources to someone else you can still
love them but you might have to love
that person from a distance
[Applause]
[Music]
so in this true crime documentary that
we just watched
it's called The X-Files
I think it's called like chasing the
ghost or something like that but you'll
find it it's on Netflix really really
fascinating but one of the um one of the
things that United all the people that
got conned once they found out they were
kind is they all had a difficult time
getting over it
and it wasn't because of the money they
lost
it was because of the fact that they got
conned
and everyone had this story going on
that says what I experienced only
happens to stupid people
how could I have been so stupid how
could I have fallen for that I'm saying
it
how could I have been so stupid you know
and sometimes when when we suffer
heartbreak or disappointment or setback
it's tempting to subscribe to this
narrative that says if I were a good
person
if I were a smart person if I were the
right kind of person this would have
never happened to me and the fact that
I'm in this situation means that I'm
fundamentally wrong in a way that normal
sane healthy people are not
but the Temptations had it right when
they said Everybody Plays the Fool no
exception to the rule right the rich and
the poor the smart the successful the
pretty people the people whose unique
form of beauty is not celebrated
everybody
right like Everybody Plays the Fool
everybody gets their heart broken
everybody has moments and I would
encourage you as you go through this
process
to perhaps be friendly to yourself
and maintain contact with yourself
and forgive yourself for even being in
this situation where you have to make a
choice like that in order to be healthy
everyone has their own version and
variation of stories like that because
we each have an evolutionary Journey
where we have to grow into the best
version of ourselves and none of us are
free of having to go through our own
version of Hell there's nothing wrong
with you for having to go through this
and you can always take the perspective
of asking yourself how can I learn from
this without carrying around the baggage
that says I should have known better
than that
oh
awesome
did you enjoy this Standalone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalist private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com the minimalists or
click the link in the description your
support keeps our podcast and YouTube
Channel 100
advertisement free